PROFESSOR: Hi, here we are in
week four, can you believe it?
We're going to be
taking a quick look
at using your mobile devices
in your camera phones.
And we're also going to
take a very superficial look
at making videos.
Superficial in the sense
that we're not going
to teach you step-by-step.
The idea is for you to
use what you've already
learned, which is an
extraordinary amount,
in terms of making
your still pictures
and applying it
to making videos.
And we'll show you by example
of some very, very interesting
videos that people have made
of science and engineering.
I'm going to take a
look at my notes here.
So we'll take a quick look back.
Natasha has some comments and
takes that she saw in the week
about light.
Let me just quickly
tell you who Natasha is.
Natasha is the one
responsible for creating
the videos in terms
of fabricating them,
all of these tutorials.
The way we worked
was the following.
I just did not want to make
talking head tutorials.
It's not my style.
And this is, of course,
all about pictures.
So the idea was for me to
collect 20 years of images,
and some recent
ones, too, of course.
And then when it was
created storyboards.
Which then Natasha
collected the images
I gave her and overlaid the
voice overs that I made.
And we went back and forth
and we edited this and that.
And then she added
some of her magic.
And that's how we got
the videos that we
got, which I think work, I
hope you think they're working.
I think that we're
getting comments
from you that you're
enjoying the videos, which
is part of this.
It's not only learning,
but enjoying the stuff.
Because otherwise why bother.
So if you remember a while ago
I said, please read your manual.
And your manual will
talk about white balance.
Some of you are not balancing
your light properly,
in that we saw this
more in this past week.
It's very simple.
It's just a means of telling
the camera what temperature
to adjust the images for.
An you'll find a better.
We'd reality rather
you do that here
while you make the pictures and
not do it in post-production.
It's something that you
might want to look at.
OK.
So that's it.
Here we go in week four.
Have fun.